there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello everybody out there
it's episode 137 yeah we're going
underground again and to Russia yeah
gonna have to go see old Eve on the
terrible
check out his library if indeed he does
have a literary there
yeah it's rumored to be underground or
needs Kremlin yeah and it's always been
a fascinating story about this you know
because there's all supposedly there's a
whole bunch of stuff in this missing
library that would rewrite history
yeah or at least be super cool stuff
that we thought was long-lost yeah but
you know we'll see otherwise well the
interesting thing was that I had
actually had this on the list for a long
time because I remember seeing I think
it was that documentary that was on
History Channel or whatever it was I
think it's called the myth hunters and
it's on YouTube and dailymotion if you
want to go check it out um so I had seen
that a while back and I'm like oh that's
a really interesting story because I
love books I love libraries and that's
like and I love like creepy like lost
underground things so I was like
fascinated by that story and said oh
well we'll do that like on the show like
one of these days but then when we were
doing the show about underground stuff
well now when we were doing the show
about the Romanovs and stuff like that
which was like two weeks ago right and
then you I think you mentioned that Ivan
the Terrible library and then somebody
in the comments was like oh yeah you
should do a show on that Ivan think I
first I think I first mentioned it in
our underground show though you probably
did that's so we moved it up and yeah
yeah
the order because like I said I have a
huge list and I have everything for the
rest of the year like scheduled out but
if I think of something I'd rather do
then I'll push that up to the front so I
kind of felt like doing this one and you
know a lot about this one too this is
like a fascinating topic for you yeah I
probably spent fascinated about what's
underground yeah yeah I saw a program
and program showed an abandoned mine I
think it was a bauxite mine underneath
the ground here in the United States I
might have been somewhere underneath
Louisiana I don't really remember
exactly what it was we I did have a
viewer who thinks that they remembered
that show he had told everyone I got to
go back and see what it is in this mine
was an entire American town with a
housing complex a main street traffic
lights everything was underneath there
because the miners and all the families
lived underneath there and if you were
standing outside you just think you're
outside at night yeah you couldn't see
the roof had regular streetlights in it
and everything and then well they were
doing a tour in there and they went
inside where the miners used to live
like in the in the apartments and
everything was just as it was left I
think was like back when the 60s of the
fifties have they even had like all the
cars and [ __ ] like that all there was
too much trouble to wish to go back up
to the surface yeah they had a lot of 30
years where the cars they had old cars
from the 50s that were just abandon in
there they just leave them in there well
but you went into where the apartments
were and all the beds were still made
the calendars just spooky spooky that
[ __ ] just totally I love that kind of
stuff I love that kind of stuff where
people's stuff is left
that's why I love all there's like urban
explorer channels yeah it's left like
underneath the ground what was the last
day that people were here what was that
like
yeah well imagine if somebody knocked
you out yeah and then put you in that
underground town and left you there and
you woke up you would even know where
you were no you're the whole town I have
to say um some people might be weirded
out by that but I saw like a um like a
show like a long time ago about like you
know crazy extreme houses or something
like that and there was a whole episode
about people that like lived underground
they'd like made essentially houses out
of like caves and [ __ ] like that they
were like I'm
I would be like I would totally do that
yeah I don't need to see the Sun ever
keep my complexion nice and pale the way
it is I don't need to go out in the
[ __ ] Sun it's not just me because you
know I know that there are thousands and
thousands of miles of abandoned tunnels
and tunnels and mine shafts underneath
United yeah you know this program said
that if you looked at a road map the
United States there's that much again
underneath underneath right and we were
talking about it we did that show and
when we went to see that movie
us yeah it started with a quote saying
that they got written that there were
thousands and thousands of miles of
tunnels yeah an abandoned town which has
to do with the story of yes yeah
honestly I look I know it's like some
people it's like most of the sound like
I [ __ ] love to us and actually I want
to go see it again yeah when we saw that
come up on the screen I was elbow to
Jenni man he's I know he did he saw much
day he saw a show but you know I guess a
lot of people are kind of fascinated
with what yeah I love that cuz and like
I said you know when we did that show
going underground which is what like
[ __ ] that was like 26 episode 26 and
was a long time ago and that was
actually one of the most fun ones to do
I think it got like the least amount of
views it's probably got a lot more now
because it's about submarines and I'm
constantly I am fascinated by that kind
of [ __ ] I love caves I love all that
kind of [ __ ] and so that's why the whole
ivan the terrible' library thing that's
why that came up well because i mean
it's not a crazy proposition I mean
Moscow does have provably like a bunch
of underground caverns and yeah the
Kremlin is totally boys and [ __ ] like
that there's all that kind of [ __ ] under
there and they don't really don't know
what yeah what's down there exactly yeah
because we're talking about going back
to the 1400s 1500s it's been totally
undermined just a war and of
interconnecting and sometimes non
connecting tunnels yeah and they're not
just dug they're just not just in the
earth they actually have stones and
brick yeah to keep them from collapsing
you know that's I mean it's all
forgotten yeah I feel like particularly
you know Europe Asia stuff like that
because they've been around so much
longer than
the United States I mean yeah we have a
bunch of like underground [ __ ] that was
probably from you know the Cold War era
and stuff like that but I mean Europe
they just kept building [ __ ] on top of
other [ __ ] and they're just like just
levels and levels and levels of just
like [ __ ] under they're just like yeah
so we're gonna get into a why it's
rumored that you've on the terrible has
a library in there we get into that but
there's probably shout out so we have to
do before beginning there is now the
first thing we wanted to shout out was
our newest patron who is named Amanda
hey that's my sister's name um so hi
there and thank you very much for your
support um I also wanted to do I know we
don't really do news stories anymore
because we started doing that for a
while that was a pain but um we did a
show like several episodes ago about
creepy disappearances missing people
stuff like that that was like the second
I think that was like the second volume
of that show what we had done and we
actually talked about the case of Jamie
cloths on that show and one of our
listeners messaged me just today and
said you know just a couple of days ago
the guy that did that just pleaded
guilty to it so you should like mention
that kind of thing so I figured so I
went and looked for the news and I said
okay well we'll just mention that the
beginning the show so if you remember
you go back to the show that where we
talked about Jamie cloths
she was the one where she was 13 years
old and somebody broke into the house
killed both her parents and kidnapped
her and then kept her captive for like
88 days at which point she escaped you
know so she's alive but her both her
parents are dead sadly and you know so
she later went on and they and they did
catch the guy who did it
his name is Jake Patterson he was 21
years old
Jamie Claus was 13 when she was abducted
he didn't actually the weird thing was
that he didn't actually know her but he
had just like seen her around and for
whatever reason just thought I'm gonna
kidnap her yeah I think I saw the whole
thing where he said that he didn't know
why he did it
yeah
right and he said so like you know the
news was they caught him like pretty
soon after she escaped which I think it
was like last October or something like
that and so he just like came to trial
and he pleaded guilty because he said he
didn't want the family to have to get to
the trial and blah blah blah which you
know thanks you should have done it to
start with but you know it wasn't all
there I don't think no it really does
seem very strange and like they kind of
talk to you like one of the one of the
articles I was reading about I think was
from the New York Times or something
like that where they were talking to
like one of his former teachers like
high school teachers know like that
saying he was very quiet he's very book
is she kind of kept to himself and stuff
like that but he doesn't really seem to
have any reason for what he doesn't know
why just for some reason he saw her and
he was like yeah looks like kind of like
an aimless guy anyway gotta do just some
insel drives around if he has a car
brian's advice well he know he did
because when he took her he put her in
the trunk and the creepy thing check
this [ __ ] out like he goes in the house
right he kills her parents he puts her
like he ties her up he puts her in the
trunk and then you know the cops are
coming to the house and [ __ ] like that
and he's just like driving slow like
past the cops with the little girl and
his [ __ ] trim yes and he told about
that at the [ __ ] yeah hearing or
whatever yeah so yeah so he pleaded
guilty so I don't know what's gonna
happen that I think it was two days ago
that he pleaded get what state is that
you know um it is I'll tell you in just
a second its Wisconsin Wisconsin yeah
if for I don't have a death penalty um
Wisconsin hmm I'm not sure that that's
kind of one of those could be couldn't
make a life I don't know but it just
seems I don't know that just seems
really weird really weird and I don't
know like he pleaded guilty to you know
the two homicides and the kidnapping
apparently they're trying to charge him
with burglary too but why bother that's
what I mean at this point it's like he's
art it's already two counts of murder
and [ __ ] roadmapping and he kept her
[ __ ] prisoner for however long over
eighty eight days so you know he was a
he'd actually like signed up for the
Marines and
like that but I think he was only there
for like five weeks in bootcamp and
didn't make it and he didn't make it
home yeah so I don't know why he did it
he doesn't seem to know why he did it it
was just one of those things which is
really scary because like you don't know
these people like [ __ ] wandering
around they don't have any [ __ ] idea
of why they do what they do it just came
over him yeah yeah that's terrifying I
don't really believe it I think that
makes me never one I actually don't
believe her I thought he was fantasizing
about abducting some girl he saw the
opportunity he did it that's what I
think he's gonna admit he just didn't
want to admit to it yeah maybe he didn't
I mean I have to give no props that he
actually did plead guilty yeah I did it
I don't have to go through dudes just
that dudes just don't have to drop it
hat go you know what I'm gonna kill that
family take that girl you have to like
think and I think about it long and hard
you don't just wake up one morning go
yeah yeah he was he was driven to do
that that would be super weird if that
was I mean that would be super scary if
that was the world was really like that
the world was if you just woke up one
day and decided yeah like I said was I
think we mentioned this on one of our
serial killer shows it's like nobody
wakes up one day and says you know what
somebody's head off I'm gonna start
today yeah a resolution someone Chuck
cut some chicks head off and I'm gonna
put a lipstick on the head and smack it
around and have sex with it said Ted
Bundy a dead boy dad he was thinking
about that [ __ ] for a long time
obviously yeah yeah that was something
he was like imagining yeah yeah
necrophile because that's what you do
you like fantasize about something for a
really long time and then you finally
like get up the gumption to like go out
and do this did he put it up on that put
it up on the mantel over the over a
fireplace mentality at it or his
fireplace or something where you staying
why we see yelling at it didn't do
something just man respect him didn't
respect him a severed head yeah yeah it
was disrespectful if I if I have my
story straight I mean I read so many
books like that so long ago but I think
it was yeah pretty sure was him and
there's so many like [ __ ] up serial
killers I guess I get details good for
you
yeah but yeah I like to keep reminding
people it's like Ted Bundy was not the
hot serial killer he was the serial
killer that yelled its everday he was
only a little bit bigger he's only a
little bit better than Gary Ridgway and
Gary Ridgway you know the Green River
Killer he'd go back to him after they
were rotten he's a rotten girl that did
that to you but I think he drew the line
at well well they're getting a little to
run you know a little to rock yeah and
then you won't go back to him nan Ridge
would go back to his wife they asked him
they asked Gary Ridgway says why don't
you do that he goes cuz it was free you
remember his voice October free do you
know what that's the same thing that he
says it was free when we get a Waffle
House yeah it gets a sausage biscuit and
it puts grape jelly on it and hot sauce
and hot sauce I said why do you do that
he said because it's free
yeah that's Mississippi thinking it's
there it's there so I'm gonna plate it
on the bottom makes it sweet and hot
it's I'm just I'm Basco and grape jelly
I'm just for you British people jelly is
not our jelly is not your jailer yeah
that's our jelly is is you know the
thing that you jam that you do jello
shots with you think you've mixed with
alcohol and then yeah
peanut butter and jelly is peanut butter
jam it's not peanut butter and jelly
like you guys think it's not Jam is
slightly different because in ms
preserved like preserves it has like
munched up for you to it doesn't have as
much sugar right jelly is very sugary
yeah it has pectin yeah no and it has no
fruit in it it's just like gel it's like
it's like jellified juice and it's very
sweet that's right it's sweeter than
Jam it's cheaper than Jam it's cheating
yeah well like I said because not to put
real fruit if we for you British people
everything if you like if you like jam
you probably you you jelly is a good
substitute so Sam but what's a jam
that's from that's from art from dan dan
bell yeah but he had like Susan Powter
there's Jim over in Jan's over and over
yeah and that's just that's whatever
mighty man if you like jab then you
would love preserves preserves isn't the
American version of jam but stick it to
extreme it's just
candied fruit yeah and you put it on
bread and we're not even starting the
whole thing with the biscuits cookies it
because the [ __ ] that I bring British
people in European people that ships
breads like a wildfire
I brought Kukulcan to the UK I got
people on Tom chitti's movies asking me
what you know how to blend this this is
a huge hit in the UK it's a good drink
if I like tequila I would probably drink
anymore
I just don't like yea kilo but you and
sweet for you people don't know what I'm
talking about it's the standard mix
equal parts is silver tequila sometimes
represent all the silver tequila
pineapple and guava juice and nectar
yeah like equal parts yeah yeah
pineapple juice and glob into equal
parts
alright now you can up to ratio if you
want to make it stronger but equal parts
is see if you want to get [ __ ] up
master I mean you can put as much and
it's called Lord Kukulcan and he reveals
himself to each person and they don't
weigh instead of saying that you're
drunk you can say you're fronting with
rival Coco we got a shirt more like a
hundred percent more about us yeah yeah
what's that we'll hammer in part by the
end of this show it will III fear that
it's happening already look we got to
get to the show well I know well listen
people don't know our show they get
pissed off they said these people talk
too much
this is a long-form show it's on a long
format show this is for people who are
working they're commuting they're laying
in bed going to sleep they want to hear
the bedtime stories or they just want
something to pass the time we're gonna
give you a real good show I'll say some
[ __ ] that'll trip you out and we'll make
it make you laugh also we do not know
the meaning of second take we are pretty
much control the way I I was like some
someone was commenting earlier today or
yesterday that it's like I you know I
love you guys so much cuz you just do
everything in like one long take which
we generally do I think the most I
ever taken out of a show it was maybe
two or three minutes I forgot something
and had to look it up or something
comments from these [ __ ] teenagers in
here man there I could find this out on
on Wikipedia
ten minutes get on [ __ ] Wikipedia
dudes over there talking about some of
the greatest shows of all times like
like what was his name art Bell you know
I mean he would take a pretty small
subject and stretch that [ __ ] out for
three hours but I'd loved it I loved it
I can sit there listen to that so it's
like an acid Arvika pedia you can find
out anything anything in two second yeah
right I mean the whole point is that you
want to like hang out with somebody on
top we're gonna talk about it and we're
gonna give commentary say commentary on
Wikipedia commentary gird your loins
yeah for the fired commentary about
right the lost library of Ivan the
Terrible also have like a little short
list of like other lost libraries
throughout history that we might mention
or not but you know mostly that we'll
talk about you know we're talking about
this lost library the library itself is
rumored to be badass we're gonna
probably talk about the books that are
supposed to be in here but really what
makes this an interesting topic is the
Russian dudes that over the years tried
to find this thing yeah some serious
dudes have been looking for this thing
over the over the eons yeah I must say
decades cuz like I said this is
something that this isn't like you know
you know it's not like oh I'm going to
the Himalayas to look for the Yeti or
nothing like that it's a library it did
exist at one time yeah they just don't
know where exactly it went to yeah you
know what I mean I know my ideas we have
opinions on what you know where this
thing is but you know what what do we
know yeah all right so I'm just thinking
there's certain amount of probability
involved with this and yeah and you can
kind of like go well what has happened
in the past
how long does things make it out of
paper last what are the conditions for
underground we'll get to that a bit yeah
so
let's kind of go back to the origins of
the library because they did not start
with Ivan the Terrible they actually
started right around the time of his his
grandfather's time who was Ivan the
third otherwise known as Ivan the great
yeah and this was the middle of the 15th
century yeah and if you think Russians
are badass today back in the 1500 god
damn these dudes they were Dracula they
were all Dracula as a whole country
[ __ ] dragon country yeah you didn't
make that movie yeah I'm gonna make that
movie we're gonna make that movie
I mean I'm gonna make I'm gonna write a
screenplay called an entire country
address yeah yeah I would watch that
[ __ ] back in the day yeah so it's the
15th century middle of the 15th century
now the Ottoman Empire has been you know
spreading to the west so they're heading
towards Constantinople so you know it's
getting threatened by the Turks and
everything like that everyone's like
freaking out it's like yeah it survived
like an earlier onslaught from Christian
Crusaders back in the 1200 s you know
what it kind of you survived that but
you know so at this stage the Sultan who
was Muhammad the second he has a hundred
and fifty thousand dudes like heading
toward Constantinople now the ruler of
Constantinople the time was constantine
xi now he had an army but it was
significantly smaller than the turkish
army so he was kind of [ __ ] bricks
yes they say um so what he what he says
he's like okay now his niece was a girl
named Sophia now I've seen it spelled a
million different ways but paleo loggia
paleo log a paleo I've seen like various
variations of it she gets married off to
Ivan the third who was Ivan the
terrible's grandfather they're trying to
like establish you know a bond between
kind of the Eastern Orthodox Church
Church and the Holy See in Rome so
they're trying to like you know it's a
like a political alliance right there
yeah because they were under a lot of
stress and you you know well the the
attacks from the art front from the
Turks back in those days man the Turks
were [ __ ] fierce they were I don't
want to get involved in this we got to
stay focused
yeah I mean if you have something to
contribute then you may contribute it
badassery was 360 degrees back then it's
just they were all bad 60 360 degrees
badass all the way around it was a time
in which I should have lived I should
live back in those days man love no
showers though but you know how to work
something out I don't know man video
games the East was rough man it was I
mean it was it was that was that was
like medieval Europe all the way up
until the hit 1900 something that's how
rough Eastern Europe was yeah you know
the whole thing about the eastern roman
have the eastern empire and fighting
against the Turks that was it was bad
they were capturing each other raising
each other's children intermarry and
other people I don't want to get
involved see like it's very funny
because you're always like you wish you
lived back at that time I'm very glad I
did not live back at that time it was
Mad Max days really that's what I mean
is very much well I guess because one I
like showers and the Internet
but also because I'm a girl and I feel
like if I had been born any time before
the 19th century I would have been
burned as a witch life was short and
brutal yeah back in those days and no no
we meant no noblemen in royal class
people had the power of life and death
over peasants and just regular people it
was just like out of fury road really
yeah see that I don't think that would
have been a good that's why every time I
see like all these people like depends
on what you're looking for you see like
oh I'm like you look like doing like
rent fares and stuff like right yeah
there's a Renaissance Festival and stuff
like that I'm like in real life you
would be like covered with scabies and
that would be like [ __ ] you didn't
live long yeah there's a lot of fighting
disease written out of poverty no thank
you
you know you you were lucky if you had
some money and things to work with and
professional soldiers you know you might
bask in glory for a short period of time
chances are you die yeah you killed but
you know all depending on what you were
looking for and those people had a
different meaning in life you know
well you'd most of them had no meaning
at all they were just basically slaves
yeah you know but you know some some of
them did kind of have you know I guess
you could say noble lives if you're on a
judgment you know judging as far as
warrior virtue goes you know there was
there was some of those but that's not
what this tale is about I gotta get back
to what we talked about on this so
you're the one that's doing this to me
you're leading me down these paths oh
yeah I'm gonna blame it on Jenny well
I've been on junior and blame it on
Google car what else is new yeah like I
said I'm a woman we get blamed for all
right so now Sophia whatever her last
name is yeah I've seen it spelled like
40 different ways she's kind of like the
linchpin of this whole situation because
she goes from Constantinople to Moscow
to marry Ivan the third now with her
stuff like it was either part of her
dowry or part of what she was bringing
with her now
the records state that it was a hundred
carts and I've seen some sources say
that each cart had like or I don't know
if each cart had or if it was like a
total of 300 boxes of very rare books
yeah and these travelled overland all
the way to Moscow and she got there very
and she got there safely okay now hold
on before this goes any further this is
the library of Yvonne the terrible okay
but we have to remember you you have to
remember that this is not going to
Yvonne the terrible this is if this is
going to Yvonne the terrible's
grandfather yeah this is before you so
this is a long time before even Yvonne
the terrible lived yeah so this is a
very important part of this story if you
ask me I mean I know that this is that
these are rich and noble families not as
much happened every year back then is
what happens now but I got very little
from my grandparents okay
makes me wonder
how many books did Yvonne the terrible
actually get from this yeah
how many of them had been sold by the
time he inherited this library that's
the kind of stuff that I'm thinking
about but go ahead yeah well and you
have to take into consideration - and
I'm probably gonna do this a little bit
later is that Ivan the Terrible was also
an avid collector of books himself Rus
so he may have added to the library or
he may have traded some volumes out or
you know who knows nobody really knows
like what was in there
as far as the so far as we know the
story says that these really cool books
that supposedly existed in the
environment that von the terrible's
library most of these cool books came
from his granted his grandmother yeah
all right there's no proof of this but
this is where the stories I mean like I
said the record said that when she
arrived in Moscow to marry Ivan the
third Ivan the great phone otherwise
known as she arrived with a hundred
carts full of rare books yeah we know
that happened yeah that did happen so
there was a library at some point I'm
saying we don't know how many of those
books right we're still actually existed
during the lifetime of monetarily we
don't know this is a mystery mystery so
we don't have a list of those books we
just know there was a bunch of books
yeah I mean there was a list at some
point but I'm not sure how there was
another list that's what I'm talking
we're talking about a list from those
days right I don't think a catalogue
back then or if they did it but I
couldn't find it I looked I looked yeah
there may have been one there may been a
list at one time but today we don't know
what books she brought right we don't
know now they're thinking though I mean
most sources that I said that I've seen
said that the books that she brought
included like some kind of lost works or
you know works that were referenced in
other works of art at the time but we
don't have them you know by Tacitus by
cicero livius --is history of Rome like
many more volumes than are extant
nowaday you know this list you're
talking about now right yeah I thought
that this list appeared much later
it did but there's a good chance yet the
guy who made this list made this list up
yeah that's not damn that's the thing
because there has to be a steady chain
of evidence yeah but let's get to this
listen yes keep going now and like I
said you know you have to think at the
time and most people probably know this
but you know before the advent of you
know widespread printing and widespread
you know book publication and stuff like
that I mean books were very very
valuable objects a lot of them were
written by hand you know some of them
were you know bound with like jewels at
like jewel encrusted stuff there was
like gold and [ __ ] like that because you
know they made like special editions
like to get a little royal families and
stuff like that's their only like one
you know one or two of them in the world
um you know it wasn't like now where you
could just go to [ __ ] Barnes & Noble
and pig Barnes Noble and pick up a
[ __ ] paper bag buy a book back in
those days was kind of like buying a
damn computer yeah it was it was a big
big deal right and you know there
weren't many copies of certain kind of
books and some books there like ancient
Roman history books that were translated
into other European languages that
muhfucka might actually be
jewel-encrusted yeah and you noted a
near priceless and one book yeah you
know what I mean and that's for a king
that's not for somebody the work that's
involved exact making something like
that so a book was a big damn deal in
the fifteen hundreds yeah for a long
time they're big deals well yeah yeah
until printing press came and you know
crossed ambriano well cost came back
that was an internet at the time because
now the the information was freed up
where any old popper could pretty much
afford it but the thing is even now if
you wrote a book and you hand wrote that
[ __ ] on some parchment paper and then
you like you know you you bound it in
like some really rare leather and like
you put jewels and should not that would
still be like really oh yeah yeah so
it's the same way just they didn't have
another option in these books it wasn't
just words it was also pitchers and
weird stuff inside the borders and lots
aren't working yeah looma native
management yeah which I love each page
was a work of art it was like opening up
a classic painting or something like
that they weren't you know they were
serious you know they were they were big
into quality back then and honestly if
you've ever been like I've been to UM
you know like the Met in New York and
stuff like that they have their whole my
favorite part of the Met is the medieval
section and they have a lot of
illuminated manuscripts in there and
they are so so beautiful and even like
the you know I don't know if they've
been like restored or whatever but even
now when you look at them even though
they're you know 500 600 700 years old
like the inks in them and so it's just
so vibrant and they're just like so
beautiful to look at so I can see why
people would make a like a huge deal and
they're just like really really valuable
objects so Sofia comes with all these
books among other things you know she
comes to Moscow she marries Ivan the 3rd
now they were kind of hoping like I said
and that this that their Union would
like kind of cause you know the the two
like the Holy See in Rome and like the
Eastern Orthodox Church it would like
kind of bring them together and they
would like help fight the Turks and
stuff like that well that didn't work
out quite the way they wanted to say
it's just the whole country and all the
Dracula's in the country of Dracula yeah
they knew so you know even though they
married like the two churches were like
nah bro we don't want any part of that
so you know then the armies didn't get
together either and then you know
inevitably Constantinople ended up
falling to the Ottoman Empire yeah so
Constantinople gets all [ __ ] up it's
like [ __ ] cannons and troops and it's
just like yeah surrounded the Navy like
overwhelmed the whole [ __ ] like I
said their army was like ten times
larger that city now is known as
Istanbul yeah and it was taken our own
system Baal the churches were converted
to mosques and whatnot so there was a
whole you know massacre pillaging
everything like that
now what Ivan the third did at the time
now the Kremlin was there during his
time
but it was made of wood now when Sophia
came there with the library among other
things she's like okay well you guys
have fires like all the time yeah this
is this is very important yeah which
they did so she's like well we need to
you know make this better so that all
our [ __ ] doesn't burn down so what she
suggested and what Ivan the third ended
up doing was building the Kremlin pretty
much as you see it nowadays so they did
it all that one stone and brick a lot of
the brickwork that you see at the
Kremlin nowadays is original from Ivan
the thirds time also started building
some underground vaults to house the
library and like I said this is where
the whole thing comes from so
unfortunately they also in the vaults
and everything like that
they also said well while you're down
there why don't you build some like
prisons and like cells and torture
chambers and like you do like you do
somebody you don't know put the books
over here with the torture chamber over
there cuz that's how that's how they
rolled in the footwell only register
only rich people can build underground
and underground is very secure so you
put a lot of your secret stuff there
back in those days that was a high-tech
secret [ __ ] yeah but there's problems
with that but you know flooding is
always a problem yeah I mean I guess the
thing is it's like if you're gonna build
so just gonna build an underground vault
I mean like I said the Kremlin when you
know Sophia came there it was made of
wood yeah and [ __ ] that's made of wood
burns down and they had fires like all
the time it wasn't just from like
attacks and so it was just like normal
[ __ ] like oh I kicked over a lamp oh I
burned everything that burned down the
whole town yeah yeah no real
professional fire departments and also
the building codes you know buildings
were right up one up on top of it all
burned down pretty much and I mean look
at [ __ ] 1666 over the Great
destroyed like half the [ __ ] city and
it's just like and you deal with people
that you know they were dumb back then
they didn't think things out a lot you
know
sanitation wasn't wasn't it was
short-term thinking and very short yeah
well [ __ ] they didn't really think in
the long term some of those medieval
cities I mean they would just build a
new level on top of the street because
there was so much [ __ ] horseshit that
they were instead of cleaning this [ __ ]
is too much work let's just build
another Road on top of it that's like
they don't stir weird you know I mean
that's not so like you know it's like oh
my god my floor is so dirty and oh yeah
yeah I'm just gonna like build like a
little bridge and I'm just gonna put
I've thought about doing that before
not in this house I'm just yeah build a
whole other house on top of my house cuz
I don't feel a military man
spick-and-span yeah I'll run the vacuum
cleaner up in here I'm not gonna fight
about Zagat I'm the one that runs the
vacuum cleaner in this house well I'm
the one that does all the laundry it
does all the other gesture you write all
the books I do the laundry you all the
video you cookin clean okay can create
and fix cars except I have to clean the
bathroom because you don't ever do that
yeah well hey guy divide it up sometimes
you know the man yeah we're fighting
about cleaning the shower and we're all
work that's why people like this show
because you're seeing is real time
relationship discord oh I'm just kidding
he actually he mopped the floors just
like less than an hour ago we're like
right before we started with a yes I
like spick-and-span kitchen yeah you
know fashion I do not like I don't mind
like a house being cluttered but I do
not like a dirty I don't even like a
cluttered and I do not like a dirt
pickup shoes and move all kind of stuff
you have women are what I'm talking yeah
don't shoes down yeah there shouldn't be
there but they shouldn't be there I'm
let I'm allowing that okay good okay
mister leaving your sweatpants on the
floor by the side of the bed that's what
they belong though
that's my space this is my spot for and
all your dirty coffee mugs yeah that's
that's something you do dear dear need
after wait after you wake up all the
coffee mugs yeah and the next day I find
the same one yes
so okay so other than you know
the Kremlin burning down says made up
would somebody also said hey you know
that the Vatican would probably love to
get their grubby little hands on this
library that you have because it is
super awesome and so maybe we should
build this vault to just like hide the
[ __ ] from them so they don't like come
in here and be like hey we heard you had
all these rad books and can we have a
look at those and then they would take
him so there was that whole time - now
at the time like I said as far as I know
historically these vaults did exist they
were built by an Italian architect whose
name was Rodolfo or Aristotle D fort
fioravanti I guess I guess is how you
say it so he's the one that constructed
these vaults like to put these books in
and to put other things and [ __ ] like
that I didn't know that yeah so
supposedly they were closing off like
waterways that [ __ ] like that because
the river kind of went all around it
[ __ ] like that's they have kind of
closed it off so it wouldn't flood and
then kind of keep the walls lined with
brick so water wouldn't seep in there
and stuff like that now even though that
is evidently a part of the historical
record they don't really know how
extensive you know the underneath of the
Kremlin is you know what I mean but they
it is now there's a lot yeah well and it
was more like as the year run on because
like I said this was several hundred
years ago right so there's been a lot
more dug under there like in the
meantime so meanwhile years go on Ivan
the 3rd dies now the succession actually
goes to his grandson Ivan the 4th
otherwise known as Ivan the Terrible
yeah now this is where it gets
interesting now he's called Ivan the
Terrible and he was terrible
um I'm just saying that when they called
him the terrible actually terrible meant
more like awesome in the sense of like
awe inspiring all right yes you know
what I mean so even though he there's a
lot of like stories about [ __ ] that Ivan
the Terrible got up to and you know
supposedly he was like a pretty awful
person said he could drink 3 liters of
vodka
I thought all Russians could train 3
liters of vodka at a sitting and still
remain talking he evidently would take
enemies time up he throw them in boiling
water and pull him out real fast and
then thumb and ice-cold water said he's
CCAP yeah I don't know if that works
that like that sounds like a legend and
evidently another thing that he would do
is if he if he made it mad eat I yet me
throw you in a giant frying pan fry yeah
I don't know if that's true that's the
way I wonder if he had like somebody he
had some guy like make he's like yeah
whatever you want a big answer I'm gonna
have to put a person a person in it
right you don't ask me why I want it
let's see I could top him on that
alright cuz I'd have the spatula made
you know that's how I roll you know I
also have a giant toaster made like a 10
or even four people if you have one of
the ones that is like two at once yeah
there's a lot of rumors about the guy I
don't know how much of it is historical
he probably sucked a lot but I think he
was a dick yeah but I think some of that
sounds like legend to me some of it
might be a countess Bathory situation
there's like she did kill a bunch of
people but maybe some of them were lurid
like some about what she did to them was
maybe exaggerated maybe not though maybe
he was just that imaginative although I
like your spatula idea you've on
everything like do conjures letter you
know they say he liked black magic and
there was the reason why he was
collecting these books is anybody trying
to figure out yeah a lot of people were
kind of you know all these stunts like
he'd be out in the woods
with his buddies mini vanish and then
they go where it [ __ ] Yvonne go then
then go back to the palace and he'd be
in there sitting throne like nothing
ever happened
so they suspected that there was tunnels
that he knew that he had tunnels yeah
they would go out to the woods so he
could secret himself so he could do like
some David Copperfield [ __ ] and you know
you would say like why would a dude
build tunnels so back in those days man
the leaders were all paranoid of
assassination all the time so they
wanted a secret well and big dick here
they were there yeah it's all justified
it actually there's something to that
because they got assassinated a lot yeah
over the years you know not just in
Russia but everywhere you know cuz you
make enemies you know [ __ ] man back then
you sneeze on somebody wrong and
somebody would assassinate during this
period if you were too nice you were
making enemies they just saw that his
weakness I mean this is a brutal time
yeah like I said you know being fearsome
and having a badass medieval type
reputation for skinning people alive it
was probably the way yeah it's probably
way to keep your ass alive
I think Vlad the Impaler also went that
yeah yeah you know just like you said
you wanted you wanted the reputation of
being fierce superhuman almost like you
would do this fucked-up [ __ ] that nobody
would ever think of even if it wasn't
true like you would spread rumors of it
just so people wouldn't [ __ ] with you
it's like they don't even think about
assassinating me because I will peel
your skin off it makes sense yeah it
makes sense so like I said it's you know
what that makes sense to your average
pushed American you know I mean but it
makes sense if you understand whether
they really did it or not was immaterial
you said legend yeah you're basically
dealing with a with a world that's very
much like them like the old movie dune
or the book dune that's there like that
yeah yeah so I've been the terrible like
I said you know all these legends about
him skinning people alive throwing
kitties and doggies out of the windows
also he really had a hate on for the
boy arse man he did not like those boys
at all and like I said he extended to us
didn't like him either yeah I've heard
differently like the boy or I've heard
different stories of who they were I
kind of thought they were the sax and
merchants I thought that's what they
were - yeah that's what I thought they
were other people thought they were
something else I can't remember what
they said for some reason nobody liked
them yeah no one wanted to sit with them
at lunch it was some kind of trading
guild yeah that's essentially what it
was they were Nobles - right so he so
Ivan the Terrible like a you know made
builds more prisons and more stuff like
underneath the Kremlin like - how was
morsi's boyars they piss him off they
can like throw him in jail and [ __ ] like
that
he also established a secret police
called the oprichnik or approached Nicky
which were like they supposedly went
around like black horses and they had
like black clothes and it was almost
like they were the ring wraiths so he
almost kind of established it like not
like a cult but almost like kind of a
religious order that's how you do lay
yeah like there was among us and he was
like the head or whatever and like he
told them what to do and they were like
completely loyal to him that's what
that's what Hitler was trying to do with
the SS they yeah the same kind of thing
and then and everyone to death of them
and [ __ ] like that
um you know so he did some [ __ ] to the
boyars he took all their money away like
he [ __ ] did this big Massacre called
the massacred Novgorod 30,000 Russians
killed
you know the whole city pretty much
wiped out there's also a story about him
beating his pregnant daughter-in-law
until she lost the baby and then when
his son who was obviously the father of
the baby intervened he killed him as
well yeah I remember reading that I
remember reading that I wonder if that
really happened I don't know that's I've
seen that on several different
historical no problem with a lot of this
old history a lot of problems this old
histories it's difficult to verify you
only have one source and yeah really
sure if that source is biased to get
that you know what I mean yeah I you
know and we've talked about this like on
our vlad the impaler show we talked in
our account
Bathory show I'm not saying they didn't
do all these horrible things that have
been attributed to them but you have to
understand that a lot of these the [ __ ]
that was written about them was written
by people who really didn't like them
very much
yeah what's the same with like ancient
Roman history yeah any one Emperor each
book you look at they have a different
spin on him so you don't know which
one's true right just like today I
imagine if you were try to go through
the newspapers of today and you know try
to get information about a bomb or
trompe from all these different you know
five hundred years from now you that the
people in the future to have a hard time
knowing you are alive at the same time
they were alive so it's like you
couldn't interact with them you know in
a contemporary fashion run so you would
just be at the mercy of other people
writing stuff I think it's safe to say
back in her third hand I'm thinking it's
safe to say that you've on the terrible
was the [ __ ] bad-ass
not a man you wanted across well he
probably did leave a wake of destruction
you know because they drank a lot and
when you have the power of life and
death over people you know you're gonna
get out of hand you're gonna get out of
hand
oh why not give you know me I'd get out
of hand you would be completely out of
hand I would just be over here going I'd
get out of hand real quick
[Laughter]
these [ __ ] got out of hand well and
I've been the terrible also was the
first was the first one to claim the
title of Tsar yeah of all the Russia's
all of them goddamn it which comes from
Caesar Caesar yeah so you're trying to
use Chuy
yeah like established kind of a godlike
rule over your people so you can crush
them under your thumb or whatever it is
you want it Baron Vladimir Harkonnen
well you know yeah it's a shoe that's
what that's what Frank Hubert was
talking about yeah yeah so I've been the
terrible now he was supposedly how he
died was he's supposedly poisoned over
kind of a long period of time
and then he ultimately died like
evidently the poison that whoever it was
was giving him was kinda like bloat out
like he got like super bloated and he I
love this one source that I was looking
at said he emitted ghastly odors I'm
like did he just smell bad or was like
farting it was the issue I don't know
what the issue [ __ ] it wasn't poisoned
he had some kind of disease
he probably what they do he died during
a chess game famously with his friend
whatever Boris Godunov who was also
suspected of like kind of furthering his
death by saying hey have some more for
you know what Mike you know what might
give you give you ghastly odors
something like intestinal cancer
probably well yeah might have been with
that blue team yeah I probably would
that's probably all it was maybe
something weird like some kind of weird
intestinal blockage or some but it was
probably something that if you were to
see it today go well of course you know
some real [ __ ] you know probably
intestinal cancer so but it just goes to
show no matter how badass and terrible
fake or awesome that you are during your
lifetime you get intestinal cancer or
poison or whatever it was you blow up
like the Michelin Man and suddenly all
your dignity just flies out the window
yeah and that's apparently Winery yeah
although he was proud of that [ __ ] he
would be in a portrait just in with his
big ol face it was so funny about King
Henry is it said when he was young he
was a real good-looking like strapping
guy most people work and then he just
well he blew up though he was still
pretty young when he blew up he got big
but then they're like they said his leg
split open and all kind of like yeah
something was wrong with him although I
have to say this is so funny and when I
was a kid I probably believe this too
cuz you know that very famous the
portrait of Henry the eighth and they
always put like a big like turkey leg or
big chicken I get his hand that's fake
that's yeah they didn't feed him doing
that Turkey I was just like you know
well that was like something that
somebody added later so like look how
funny he's eating in the portrait
because he's so fat but that's not a
real portrait I thought it was when I
was little and then I learned correctly
later no but yes here's a poon hound
a big old fat guy run run tail well it's
not like no one could say no and it's
like if you did say no he would just sit
on you and yeah you guessed I don't want
to imagine how anybody is that Darren
smelled they all smelled bad honestly at
that time I feel like everybody smelled
so bad that it's like nobody smelled bad
because we didn't know any merit to it
was like the streets were like full of
[ __ ] it was it was it was just like
[ __ ] chemical warfare
it was stink versus stink everywhere we
were just talking about this earlier
today we're like out for a walk and you
were talking about some of the like
ruins of like ancient Roman cities and
stuff that they found you're like dude
when they found like the ruins of like
just normal people's houses yeah they'd
like the kitchen a kid never liked the
toilet oh right there and I said well
okay I said okay that's disgusting but
it's like I can understand how the
Romans might have thought that because
they thought it was all part of the
digestive process each ate it right here
and there it's convenient you don't like
it's very efficient to have partition
are about through memory so you have
this [ __ ] you have the [ __ ] right
next to the [ __ ] frying pan so you
could just eat and then usually down
yeah yeah that's all part of it even the
odors are all part of the same [ __ ]
process that's the way we're thinking it
had to be I'll have my bacon oven is why
we smell I would in a regular common
apartment why the hell would you put the
the [ __ ] right next to the [ __ ]
stove well you would have to go back in
time and ask the Romans that question
because who the [ __ ] does that nowadays
I mean you know they weren't big
apartments but you could at least put it
on the other side of the room yeah right
now did have I don't think they had
plumbing I think it was a place where
there was like a port-a-potty type thing
like a like a like a chamber pot yeah
and I don't think I think they've been
in the view of mine I know I can't
imagine I think in the apartment they
were talking about didn't really have
running water for flushing flush toilets
but it was just you know yeah it's like
here I'm gonna cook
whatever it is the ancient Roman date
I'm just gonna cook this right here and
then oh I got a pinch a loaf
yeah take two steps handy for all you
people who thought the Roman a classy to
see all that white marble statues those
beautiful those [ __ ] were painted
they were painted they were but they
were actually were painted yeah there's
[ __ ] paint residue on them on some of
them evidently but there's like all that
[ __ ] classic marble classy looking
[ __ ] no those [ __ ] were painted it
look like a damn Persian whorehouse
that's what that yeah they're probably
what so Vegas and yeah yeah they pay
that [ __ ] they painted the pubic hair
[ __ ] you know look [ __ ] stupid I bet
you did they probably all the action
agencies painting the tackiest [ __ ] all
right so like I said I haven't terrible
bloated out drop dead during a chess
game purportedly a poison no one's
exactly sure and then the location of
his famed library
kind of yeah like I said did you like
yeah yeah no it was very I could do
special effects on this year yeah thanks
yeah you make my camera go because we
have autofocus so every time like he
starts like flailing around it's just
the focus so sorry about supposedly he
had a librarian at his death they don't
know where where it went
there's a bunch of legends daddy had
special people come into [ __ ] buried
and hide this thing into the end of the
tunnels underneath the dam yeah I think
was underneath the tower the Arsenal
type Arsenal tower really sustained yeah
I mean they've been looking under there
but as wily as that dude was though I
think he'd probably try to put it in a
place that wasn't really you know where
you wouldn't suspect but I I've really
got a question this whole underground
library thing
but the thing about it is that yes the
library existed yes they think that a
vault was constructed underneath the
Kremlin to house the books to keep them
from getting burned up or you know taken
by the Vatican or whatever but in the
ensuing years we don't know what
happened to them it's like were they
still there like when Peter the Great
came in did he sell them often he moved
them to someplace else did you know did
looking Ivan the Terrible like sell them
off I'm thinking Peter the Great would
not have sold them off because if he
sold them off they'd be in circulation
and based on this somebody gave us these
books are so exotic they would have
moved to the top of the [ __ ]
desirable list yeah because they're like
Greek plays that we don't have yeah it's
like other editions a certain Roman
history books that we that people have
been looking for you know it's basically
kind of like it's like it's it's like a
bunch of holy grails the list that we
are given from a guy who says he saw of
the list
Vaughn dabble oh yeah he said he saw the
list he didn't have the list but he said
he saw it and the books that he wrote
down I think he gave about eight nine
ten of them they're they're so good
they're almost unbelievable yeah well he
said that it was like you know Libya
sees history of Rome which nowadays they
only know of thirty five volumes he said
okay well there was a hundred and forty
two volumes of that there was D
república by Cicero which is referred to
in other works but we don't have an
extent version of it it was that kind of
stuff like some unknown poetry by Virgil
all this other kind of stuff that if you
were making a list of like everything
that you were I want to have it he said
is there it's on there I think it was
some stuff from Tacitus yeah I think
there was some stuff from this Swift
odious I think there was an earliest I
think he claimed an early edition of
Josephus yeah which would have meant
that it wouldn't have had the Catholic
Church and edits that we have in our
version of Justice
put in there to support historical Jesus
yeah evidently this yeah evidently the
old Josephus would have had that yeah so
that would have blown the historical
Jesus out of the water
yeah well you can see why the Catholic
Church will run again right so there was
a bunch of cool [ __ ] no but yeah it
probably did at some stage yeah is it
time for a break it probably is all
right we'll do the break then we'll get
into the guys who have looked for this
yeah we want to specifically talk about
the most famous guy that looked for this
I mean he spent most of his professional
career looking for this yeah and there
were real dudes looking for this yeah
there was significant you know this guy
was a real archeologist he really booth
Russian guy yes so that's key yeah he
was doing this in a [ __ ] heart of the
[ __ ] Stalin period where you can get
your damn head cut off or sent to damn
Siberia big balls looking for this thing
underneath the Kremlin yep and because
of course in the Soviet empire be like
look we have real history you guys have
fake history we have real history so
yeah they were they were looking for it
yeah they believed it was there people
are still looking for it yeah right well
we gotta take a break right now you
probably got to refill his Kukulcan and
get his [ __ ] together I don't know if
I'll be able to handle anymore that yeah
maybe you should well you still have a
lot left I still have a lot left I think
we'll be all right for the rest of the
show all right so we're gonna take a
break when we move back in just a few
minutes talking a little bit more about
Ivan the terrible's lost library
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest
unsolved murders of the 20th century
volume 2 includes cases spanning the
years from 1960 through 1979 featuring
such infamous crimes as the triple
homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the
is killing fields and the mysterious
death of suspected spy the is doll woman
along with dozens of other fascinating
and horrifying accounts by it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format
[Music]
you doing believe way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
protect the paper and declared at the
end of the day at this house and will
continue to be honored there a long time
all right
we have returned from the break we
didn't get any more liquor but we did
put some more ice in our drinks yeah
that's because we're trying to keep it
together folks it's a complicated
subject it is gonna and I were getting
in the part where we're getting into
basically the Russian Indiana Jones
who's looking for this [ __ ] really if
there's any archaeologists that is like
Indiana Jones would be this guy
yeah like I said he was actually yeah
yeah this dude has some like a giant
brass balls yeah so we're talking a
little about Ignatieff I guess he's like
egg naughty or Ignatius stilinski so a
seasoned by either name born in 1878 in
the Ukraine he actually graduated from a
theological Academy but during his
travels around in Syria and Turkey and
various other places he developed a
passion for archaeology and in 1907 1907
he moved to Moscow and joined the or
entered the Moscow archaeological
Institute and he started getting
interested in you know the the
underground byways of Moscow like all
the stuff that was under under the
ground so he kind of like he got
together this group called the
Commission for the study of underground
antiquities in Moscow that was in 1912
now he had heard legends about the lost
library of Ivan the Terrible and became
let's say obsessed with the subject and
he was obsessed there's not certain that
he was going to be the person to find it
yeah and this isn't like a fly-by-night
you know guy this is a real archeologist
and he was absolutely convinced that
this library existed that's really the
only thing only part of this story that
makes me think that maybe that
it exists yeah he thought it existed
well I mean a lot of historians at the
time were like look even if the library
didn't exist at one time it was probably
broken up or it was moved ER it was
destroyed every blooded flooded like a
million things could have happened to it
but still lutzky he really believed that
it was still there underneath the
Crumlin someplace and it was like in
some hidden location and he believed
that he was going to be the only one to
fight and he pretty much spent his
entire professional life looking for it
or seeking means to look for it like
getting permission to look for it
assembly yeah and the real one of the
reasons what he thought it was there is
because there were all these legends
yeah the legend said that Yvonne the
Terrible commissioned of guys to come in
and translate everything it's everything
and that those guys ended up running or
getting killed or disappearing and then
they had there was legends that that
they live that library chambers were
built and then the dudes that built them
were killed or killed
to hide the to hide the location of this
library so that no one would notice of
him and that this [ __ ] was sealed up
tighter than a tick so no one can get to
it there was legit like that yeah purses
on the shoe right well because there
were legends too about like st. Basil's
Cathedral in Moscow that like the purse
that architect that had designed that
they'd blinded him so we we yeah build
anything else more beautiful so there
was kind of some precedent for this type
of legend where you know everybody that
worked on these supposed vaults
underneath they were all killed or
blinded or whatever so they wouldn't be
able to reveal the secret so that's key
thought it was there and all this other
kind of stuff so he became convinced
even though a lot of mainstream
historians were like no it's not there
it's like you know it got moved it got
would you be rational it sounds too good
to be true
it does first of all the list where the
list came from and the more on the list
yeah and we're gonna get to that that's
almost too good to be true let's talk
about that a little bit because the
whole idea and I think a lot of the
reason why still let's key was so
obsessed with it was from this
particular quote-unquote list that came
from a guy called Christopher
Vaughn de Bob who was a historian from
the 19th century now he claimed that he
had seen Ivan the terrible's library and
he had written a list of maybe not all
the books that were in it but a lot of
the books that were in it and like I
said you know the list that we have
today he's like oh there's all these
lost volumes of sweet Onias all these
lost you know poems by Virgil all these
lost volumes of Libya's history of Rome
all this stuff he had written these on
this list allegedly and so that's where
a lot of the legend stem from he's like
look I saw the library and all these
books were in it you know all those lost
books and he wrote this list down later
on stilinski said he saw that list yeah
and that he didn't he saw the list hid
he went into the guy's room or went to a
room where the list existed he's turned
it upside down he found the list and
then copied the list down see this isn't
this is something that kind of gives me
pause but I'm like why the [ __ ] you
copying the list out why aren't you just
taking a list purportedly stole etske
like I said in the 1910s he starts
looking like around 1912 1913 he starts
getting obsessed with the lost library
of Ivan the Terrible and starts wanting
to look for it
he asked the Kremlin uh you know
officials that the Kremlin if he can
have permission to dig underneath there
it was still the Czarist government of
time it was actually Nicholas the second
and we talked about on our show but the
Romanovs
and they said no so you know he was
disappointed so when he was trying to do
was he was looking for some type of
incentive some type of proof that there
was something under there that he could
look for so he could present it to the
officials and go look I think there's
something there you know please let me
look for it right he needed permission
to write because you know it's the
Kremlin you can't just go dig under the
Kremlin and not get your head shot off
yeah well it's gonna look so we dig
underneath there and that [ __ ] happen
because it's well dangerous it is but
we'll get to that in a bit in 1914
according to Celeste
he's in these archives in Estonia and he
says he's in these archives right
they're kind of a mess there's like
books and papers everywhere
he's like digging through there and
should he found that [ __ ] mister and he
said he found Vonda blogs list yeah now
the thing that gives me pause about this
was like you said why do you just snatch
the list and take it right he copied it
and then took it back and said look look
at all the stuff like here well send me
through the [ __ ] roof if you were to
take the list you could actually date
the list yeah it would have more
credence I mean more credible in 1914 um
I'm not sure how good carbon dating was
back then probably not very even back
then they knew it hope old paper looks
like even if you had taken the actual
list people would still call [ __ ] on
you be like I don't think that's real
it's fake or whatever but for sure if
you just like copied it on your [ __ ]
arm or a napkin is less credible no one
is gonna believe that you like look I
totally saw it I just read it down here
yes I wrote it on my hand
it's just that part of the story's fishy
yes so that kind of bothers I mean also
that the library is not there also the
books on that list or they're just damn
too good to be true every one of those
books is like a Holy Grail that's it
fills in these giant yes in ancient
literature like I said if a historian of
ancient literature wrote a list of every
book they wanted to find that would be
in that would pretty much be so that
kind of like it just dovetails too
neatly and that kind of another in
defense of the list yeah he said those
were the though those were the ones that
popped out because there's one or two
other ones they didn't bother to write
yeah but those were the important ones
yeah it's just weird that it's a list of
all the books that everybody wish that
everybody wish they could find it's like
yeah we you know people have been
referring to this
poem by Virgil that you it's red and
it's like oh there it is but there's
still you know there's still something
in you that's like well maybe well and
like I said this isn't a claim like this
isn't like a supernatural claim there's
no like oh I think there's like a crib
there's like a chupacabra or anything
God we're not saying that the library
the library was there at some point you
know Ivan the Terrible and he did he did
have these books and like I said he was
a book collector he probably added some
books of it to his own you know that
they don't know about so they're just
something back that it exists is not
crazy
um they there was a vault built
underneath during the time of Ivan the
third to house the books presumably
that's not crazy so it could still be
there there's just something about this
list and also that bothers me and also
perfect it's also knowing how people are
yeah that it looks like stilinski just
trying to find permission well yeah
because it it's insane constructive that
way a year or two before he had asked
the romanov you know family the imperial
family at the time if he could have
permission to they can say no please
look for this and they said no and then
I got it because at the time like
historians were like no that doesn't
exist it's been destroyed or whatever so
the fact that me the timing was a little
too much like look I got this list it's
really there please let me look for it
that just seems a little too convenient
that's that's all I'm saying I'm not
saying that it's not there I'm just
saying that seemed a little too
convenient and like I said you know he
he became so convinced that it was there
and it was like his life's work really
his last mission and but you can
overlook a lot of stuff yeah you get
like kind of tunnel vision when you're
like this is my life's work it's if I
find this it's like it's like the guy
that found Troy you know what I do it's
gonna be this big deal and everybody's
gonna but then again you see that list
and you go
you know maybe we should look what it's
like what if what's there
what if that is there right because like
those books I mean at some point maybe
they did exist if they're still around
somewhere in someone's collection that
would be awesome to know that the books
that were on that list from memory I
don't remember all of them but I just
remember thinking at the time that books
like that probably do or did exist yeah
some of them were referred to yet and
other works and we're just we just tell
them were referred to other ones were
there like probable book like that
problem that does exist but yeah it was
a badass list I mean if you had that
list you'd be the king of all kings in
terms of archeologists yeah because
you'd be you'd be filling in a lot of
blank spots in Western history right you
know and because you know it was an
ideal list of books okay what scholars
have been looking for or hoping for for
like thousand years well yeah like I
said I mean it like you said it would
fill in a lot of the gaps of what we
know about ancient knowledge a lot of
the philosophers and writers Rebecca I
mean even to the early days of
Christianity like it was Christianity a
hoax or was it real yeah that's what
these books would have promised yeah
there's like some earth-shattering [ __ ]
in there right if this list does
actually exist so as I said you know he
brings the lists of them they still
gonna buy it he's like he's having a
hard time getting permission but then
when you know after as we discussed on
our show about the Romanovs after the
Bolshevik Revolution took place the
Romanovs are assassinated that you know
Russia was thrown into kind of chaos and
turmoil and blah blah blah then you know
the Bolsheviks came in the Communists
came in and then Stalin says well he
wants to make a you know an underground
subway system it's gonna be the envy of
the world yeah so he starts digging all
around
like underneath he's gonna dig in subway
tunnels
so stilinski gets him on that [ __ ] yeah
and he's like so he actually kind of
gets in on he's gonna be the guy that if
they find anything unusual while they're
digging around for the subway system
then he's gonna be consulted about that
right and like secretly
while they're looking there find another
[ __ ] like skeletons like oh look Ivan
the Terrible killed all these people
all that [ __ ] there
so while they're party he's looking he's
kind of sneaking away at odd times and
like looking to see if he can find the
library because evidently there was
someone that had gone under there and
said that they had seen they didn't say
they had seen the library necessarily
but they thought they saw something that
looked like it was leading to the
library was and it was like all these
white stones and all this other kind of
stuff so yeah I think there's some about
following white stones you follow these
white stones were you talking about
Hansel and Gretel you know what we're
talking about is it doesn't really look
like a cave it looks more like a sewer
system underneath there there's a bunch
of you know bricks yeah tunnels that are
brick lined that's that's what most of
this looks like and later on over the
years people people added iron cages or
grille sir yeah bars to make certain
parts of it impassable and the stuff
goes back to the 1500 this is old stuff
that's what I mean there's like yeah
underneath in Moscow it's just like all
tunnels and yeah and the purpose for
these tunnels isn't really known anymore
they've you know back in the days people
knew what they were for but you don't
know what they're for today yeah we just
keep building [ __ ] on top of whatever
that was and it's like nobody everybody
forgets like everybody knew what it was
they died so you know like I said that's
why I'm not discounting the possibility
this library is still under there um a
lot I think a lot of it with secret
passages from one palace to another well
people can escape well there's a lot of
wars and stuff yeah for sure they have
that nowadays I mean they know that that
should is underwear under their
underwear underwear yeah yeah but um you
know and especially you know what's the
Bolsheviks came in what's the Communists
came in you know they built all kind of
secret tunnels under there like hey
we're gonna build this like secret
subway to go over here and oh yeah
you're never here so they could like get
away in case something bad happened
so there was that whole thing but so
still etske he kind of like he spent
like I said all of his professional life
kind of trying to get permission
together there and you know kind of
sneaking around and [ __ ] like that um he
was also he went back to the Ukraine for
a while he was a professor of
archaeology there in 1923 he comes back
to Moscow and starts doing research 1925
and he approaches the Soviet government
and asked them again if he can search
underneath the library but it took them
four or more four more years until they
said ok you can dig underneath the
Arsenal or Arsenal Arsenal nyeh tunnel
which is where he thought that the
library was most likely located so you
know even though they'd given permission
in 1929 I took a further four years
before he was able to start excavations
they start digging out under there but
they only went on for about a year
before there was like an assassination
in Moscow and they were discontinued and
he's doing this during a time you'd be
easily be killed just for sideways yeah
he really had to keep his head down but
yes and he was using ruses to get
permission he was telling head of
Stalin's security says look I think
there's these tunnels underneath here
and in order to keep Stalin safe yeah my
knees damn tall said that there was like
there there could be terrorist threats
like you know terrorists get in under
here and could get into the ghrelin so
we need to explore this that's really
how he got permission to do it and I
think he also kind of appealed to yeah
he Soviet government in a way that's
like well we need to find this Czarist
guy said yeah back to the people like
these are books that belong to every
yeah and there was also this whole thing
worth
if we do happen to find this library
will corner the market on new history
that's let's say that you know from from
Soviet might and ingenuity we have
pulled lost histories from the jaws of
time yeah it is how that's how the
commies well and also he was kind of
trying to he was thinking also that he
baby would open a museum or like said
you know tourists would come see it or
so like then it would be like a cause of
you know like a you know thing of
revenue for the government so he kind of
approached him that he wasn't a dummy
like he approached her from that angle
to cuz he really really really wanted
permission to dig under there and look
for it right so at this stage still
Otsuki has found he's been able to dig
into the Arsenal tower he's found these
quote-unquote white stones that he
thought were you know kind of the
hallmark of like where he thought the
library was he found vonda box Gate
which he said it was like this rusted
gate that he said this is the entrance
of library I never saw it but you know
that's where it was and all this other
kind of stuff
he never did find the library he was
starting to get sick around this time
and then world war ii broke out and he
always meant to go back and keep looking
for the library but sadly he never had a
chance to and he died without finding it
yeah now he died in nineteen forty nine
actually
so as the you died kind of a broken man
he did and he was kind of repeating walk
things over in different languages and
his wife was thought that he'd lost his
mind and he was still obsessing over
that damn library looking for something
your whole entire life and then whether
he was close to finding it or not we
don't really know but he thought he was
for sure like he found those white
stones he found that gate and he was
just gonna he found the list supposedly
and he's like look i must be only days
away from finding it only days away and
then one he keeps getting denied i can't
dig under there I can't do that then he
gets sick and then the war breaks out it
was all she never gets to go back down
there he got to a certain point where he
was digging and he thought he was almost
there and they hit a well which started
to flood the tunnels and had to go and
repair
the dam floods and you know he dearly
lost his head for that they'll ship it
into Siberia for collapsing the streets
because the guy that let him do it was
the head of security yep and that dude
flipped his [ __ ] lid when he found
out the big [ __ ] when they found out
that they hit that well it was a huge
collapse yeah all the way to street
level yeah cuz the street started to
collapse in or was in danger of
collapsing in it depending on what you
read and had that impeded the egress of
Communist Party officials to get into
the Kremlin they'd have been pissed if
the [ __ ] road collapse yeah I mean
that was innocent you could get sent to
damned gulag for that yeah so they
patched it up and told him they couldn't
he couldn't dig in that area and I think
they called a I think they think that's
why I actually called the digging off
when yeah isn't that what yeah because
they have a key once that happiness and
that's it to dad was secure yeah we
don't want it that bad well because you
look like you said and then at that
point like worse had broken out that was
like World War two it's like nobody
[ __ ] cared about finding a bunch of
books underneath the Kremlin it's like
so honestly his lifelong quest started
to seem like something like a pipe dream
that no one gave a [ __ ] about it except
for him because you know people had more
important problems I guess
well Soviets didn't give a [ __ ] because
they were under a lot right you know
people in the West would have really
[ __ ] paid dearly for those damn books
yeah just that you know the scholarly
pursuits were not a high priority in the
Soviet Union at that time luckily the
Soviet Union is [ __ ] it's gone now
and you have private treasure hunters
looking for this to this day yeah
they're still underneath there looking
for and honestly I would [ __ ] love it
if they found this [ __ ] yeah I would
love it but I have to say that you know
ever since you know the Soviet Union
fell and stuff like that they've been
digging underneath Moscow pretty much
continually since that time since the
1990s not only more subway tunnels or
some more secret tunnels like for
various you know government officials to
go here and there you know
just been digging as far as I know I
have heard that there as many as 12
levels like underneath street level it's
just like sewers and subways and all
kind of [ __ ] under there and so far no
one has found anything resembling the
lost library of Ivan the Terrible they
call it the Liberia or the golden
library which I forgot to mention
earlier so and it's sad because even
nowadays there's a group of people
they're kind of our urban explorers
called the Moscow diggers and they
illegally go underground like [ __ ]
around and stuff what stuff I think
every country has a group of people that
do stuff like this a lot of that going
on I know that yeah I was gonna say I
know they have that in France cuz you
know they have all those yeah skeletons
I'm sure like that underneath it's like
people that live down in the down in the
catacombs and stuff like that so the
Moscow diggers are basically go around
and around and they're not necessarily
looking for the library but they kind of
explore underground to see what they can
see they have found many many skeletons
many weapons like they've even found I
don't know if it was them that found it
but at some point they found like a
hidden cache of like Viking jewels like
all kind of like these crazy like
elaborate jewels it's stuff that they
think stem from the Viking periods they
found that under there but so far they
have not found the hidden library so
people are wondering whether or not it
really exists what do you think still
haven't found it like what do you think
you think that's there I think like I
said I think it existed at some point
but where it is now I don't know you
would think that if it had been broken
up because look at some of your other
lost famous lost libraries your life
lost libraries of like [ __ ] you know
the lost library of Pergamon the lost
library of Aristotle blah blah it's like
various books that were in those
collections turned up later in other low
Haitians you know what I mean they were
recovered from destruction and then they
were sold off and like other people
found them later on but the books that
were supposedly on this list none of
them as far as I know none of them have
turned up in anyone's collections
anywhere so yeah I have to wonder like I
said these books did exist at some point
I don't think that there was a catalogue
of them produced at the time that Sophia
brought them to Moscow in the days of
Ivan the 3rd in the 15th century
so we don't know entirely what the
entire catalogue was what books were in
there we don't know so it's like if we
did know maybe if one turned up in
someone else's collection hey I found
this but you know that got sold from
some [ __ ] nobleman or whatever back in
the day then you would know that that
was at least where that one had gone so
I don't know there's just not like not a
lot of provenance
now am I saying that it's impossible
that it couldn't be like stashed
somewhere underneath the Kremlin that is
not impossible because the Kremlin is a
huge huge huge how many like it's how
many million square miles that's a lot
of numbers Wilson square feet or
whatever it's like a huge huge area Hey
happen I can't turn [ __ ] up she's yeah
that's ridiculous ok good
but yeah so you know it's it's a large
area to explore um you know there's a
lot of levels underneath there so I'm
not saying it's impossible that library
doesn't still exist somewhere but it's
been a really long time a lot of [ __ ]
could've met it could have burned it
could have flooded um you know so many
things could have happened to it in the
ensuing time period is it still intact
as a library I'm kind of doubting it
yeah I'm not saying that the volumes
themselves don't exist somewhere else
and some random like scattered
collections but hey stop it what are you
doing why you turn the house up well I
don't know what do you think okay I
think I think the list
was a hoax I kind of think he used the
list unless he used the list a
permission yeah because he was yes
please
he's dangling yeah so I don't think
there was a lovely we do know we do know
that if I'm the terrible's grandmother
did have a bunch of books she did yeah
chances are by the time
Yvonne inherited them I think most of
those books are priced sold off that's
two generations right and you know
people need money sometimes and they did
a lot of trading and bartering or and
selling a lot of wars it happened during
that two fires had happened so I think a
lot of them were traded off or burned up
that's what I mean they call it it's
funny because they call it Ivan the
terrible's library but it was actually
diving the terrible's grandmas libraries
what they're talking it was hers and
Ivan the thirds it was the one that said
hey build the vault to put him in and
stuff like that but like I said that was
two generations yeah Ivan the Terrible
was her grandson right it was two
generation a lot can happen in that time
period and all these stories about I
found the terrible um making these
vaults for these libraries it's all
second third hand legend yeah
well he didn't make the vault he didn't
make it somebody's grandfather did no
I'm saying all these stories but he
found the terrible right there were some
of the legends that said that he had
commissioned these vaults to hide this
stuff right maybe you found a different
source that said his grandfather did it
but from what I saw it it is also
there's it's also there in the legends
that Yvonne himself
Adam hidden well yeah it's hide it built
under there but if yeah this is all
legend yeah yeah now chances are he
didn't have anything hidden uh turning
brushes they're notoriously secretive
right country I think he had his own
books but I don't think I don't think he
inherited many books from his
grandmother I think they had a raw lost
by the time he was born maybe he had a
few but it wouldn't been a library been
it would have been more like a couple of
her books in his library
ya know a lot of do too but a lot of
things can happen love you
fires to be traded stuff they sold stuff
right now the safety of him as gifts
right things right now let's say he did
have an underground vault with a bunch
of books in it storing a library well
first of all why would you do that
you couldn't access them you couldn't
read them you know you think if they
were hidden and sealed up in a vault
somewhere you might as well just throw
them away because you couldn't get to
him but let's say you did do that how
long would they remain intact in a
situation like that how long would how
long would it be before say it got
flooded by groundwater you know I mean
just a few years ago they dug up I guess
this is back in the 90s they dug up a
Cadillac they had been sealed in a
concrete vault some time back in the 50s
they thought it was gonna be pristine
then they opened it up no that [ __ ] was
just a box concrete vault on purpose to
see like a time capsule like a time
capsule and then when they opened it up
it was just a pile of rust cuz
groundwater got in there yeah it spent
most of its time underwater so you know
it's just it's not a sure thing to bury
something in a vault
something can still happen to it you
still have things like bacteria or maybe
you know maybe a small cockroach
infestation just eat that eat that up
over a period of a few decades
cockroaches will glue yeah they will eat
and let's say you seal a big library up
into a [ __ ] vault you know he's all
and nothing can get in here but the
thing is a couple of cockroaches a
little bitty cockroaches got in there
over the next decade the the descendants
of all those cop cars was gonna be eaten
up all those books yeah they don't need
sunlight that's what I mean it's like
look a smart mining of oxygen as smart
as people think they're yeah nature well
I'll have a way now let's say that you
know under ideal conditions see like you
know the Giza
burial complex down in Egypt you know
where it's an extremely dry you know and
it never rains yeah you can store
something for thousands of years there
but that's not Russia yeah yeah no I'm
just not sure that a bunch of
leather-bound pieces of paper and jewels
could survive very long bare right now
and that's a shame because if that ship
did exist it would be nice to find it
yeah but I don't know like I said you
know there was some climate is so
different I mean like I'm from Florida
like he you bury something five feet
underground here I'll just be up like
it's the ocean we'd work at sea-level
you dig down it's wouldn't last long
it's water to get that done in Russia to
get that done in Russia you'd probably
have to make sure first of all it's
nowhere near any kind of groundwater
yeah you'd have to have brick and then
you probably want to seal that up on the
inside with a bunch of plaster
you know I mean to make sure that it
everything that the moisture whacker
could give it everything everything you
could think of I think it's I'm just
gonna say that it's unlikely that that
would because and especially nowadays
because especially since you know the
1990s yeah um you know they've been
building a lot of [ __ ] underground
they've been expanding the mass air they
built like a lot of malls and [ __ ] like
that like underground balls and whatnot
um and they still haven't come across
anything that looks like a lost library
of any time I mean I know Moscow is a
big city the Kremlin is very big there's
a lot of space underneath the ground you
know I understand that but you'd think
in all this time that someone would have
stumbled across something by now by now
that suggested that and like I said I'm
not I'm not saying that it didn't exist
at some point because I mean obviously
it probably did but I don't think it's
still all in one piece I'm gonna say
sadly I'm gonna say it's very unlikely I
think that the library was ever put in
there yes I don't think he bought it
Evon would have done it okay I'll be
able to do it that way yeah he was too
busy doing other things
stored a minute restore them in a way
where he who had access to him okay well
he was say it was a book guy but
Lissette yeah so you'd want to have
access to it yeah you'd want to read
them so let's say but let's say he did
have an underground vault with a bunch
of books in it the chances of that thing
surviving to this day I think is very
slim yeah I think groundwater would have
got to it or something like they would
have found it that bums me out because I
love I love the idea of you like digging
under Moscow and then suddenly there's a
chance all but there's all these books
in there with like jewels on and but
it's like a tomb oh my god it's like
that would be such that would be so
awesome it's a romantic idea and that
could be that could good it could be I
think it's unlikely I doubt it I think
it's unlike and it's a shame because I
love the idea I love the idea of just
somebody coming across it I think it's
more likely that's a legend there never
was a library like that the books that
they're talking about were sold off
piecemeal here and there over the years
and some of them were destroyed and lost
destroyed in fires in law yeah because
your wars I mean a lot of libraries I
mean and I found with some lists and
lists of them you know particularly from
the ancient world libraries that were
known to exist but that were destroyed
and fires you know they were destroyed
during various battles what they don't
know what happened to them they were
broken up you know and they don't know
what happened to all the components so I
feel like that's probably what happened
here I probably I feel like probably
before the modern era before still let's
even started looking for it you know the
the library had perhaps been broken up
into pieces and is maybe sitting in
somebody's collection somewhere and they
don't even [ __ ] know it's a very good
chance that most of the books from
Yvonne the terrible's grandmother that
most of those books never fell into
vomit terrible's possession they were
gone by the time he was old probably
that you know I would probably think
that that's what happened to most of
them sold off probably to fund things
the building of palaces and more
to make walls that kind of [ __ ]
you know they were collectibles and they
were tradable they were worth a lot of
money yeah and like I said it's a shame
because you know we might never know
what happened to those books if they
ever did exist and that sucks I think
what happens the most books that are
kind of like of this description of the
G jewel-encrusted book I think what
eventually happens to them is that the
books themselves become kind of passe
and out of style you know I mean because
they're a hundred years old and then
whoever has imposed all the jewels out
of them and pawns those off to buy
something useful and then later on over
the next 100 years they see this book
that's just kind of you know I mean torn
up because the jewels are missing on it
they're like no this trashy old thing
that throw it away
seriously trolly what happens to a lot
of like this is hard for me because it's
like if if ever I was in possession of
some like let's say hypothetically just
some like medieval like illuminated
manuscript that had like jewels and [ __ ]
on it and then let's say I was like
homeless and starving in the street
would I be able to like tear that apart
and sell it I would hesitate well I
don't like doing that it comes a time
where certain things that are old or
just junk I know they're not they're not
they're not priceless yet they're not
that old you know I mean all that old
[ __ ] that's 50 years old [ __ ] that thing
something like that take those emeralds
out I'm gonna give those my wife will
put those on a pendant I got a better
copy of that crap I'll just wipe my ass
with the page yeah well you're dealing
with rich people of those days so they
would have gone like I have a better
copy of this you know man that's
probably what they would have said yeah
that well they weren't anxious i knows
days well and even because it it bothers
me as like a person that grew up is a
poor person it like was always like
saving stuff because it's like you never
knew when you're gonna have money to buy
a new one so it's like the fact that
people could take something that was
that expensive or
valuable and could just like whatever
yeah that's just were you doing with
people that were like Noble or royal I
know you know back in those days when
that stuff wasn't all that old they
would just would have sourced it you
know like what take all those jewels out
of there I won't bake that into a
pendant and sell that off the book I got
a better copy of that do you know
whatever I you know that the book that
and I reference it a lot on this show
that strange sure is amazing fact where
they were talking about I think they
were talking about the Hope Diamond
which is something that we should
actually do a show on that I'm
fascinated by that kind of [ __ ]
but the fact that they found this
diamond that was like huge and it was
like bigger than any diamond that it was
ever found and immediately like the
first person that owns it takes it to a
jeweler it's like man cut a bunch of
carrots off of that [ __ ] yeah I'm making
all but like a shape in like we're gonna
make this others like why did you do
that why but it's like in value it the
same way you do no they didn't it's like
it's like this huge expensive thing that
they found but they're just like yeah
cut a bunch of [ __ ] off it whatever I
can I can afford it that that [ __ ]
kills me but yeah all right so I was
gonna go into some other lost libraries
but I think we got playing it that's my
material we've got on I'm gonna talk
about two hours lost library I'm
terrible
so I guess we will wrap up episode 137
hopefully you guys have enjoyed it we
enjoyed doing it actually as drunk as we
are so if you liked the show remember
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show you can do that it
would be much appreciated you go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the
sidebar where there's a PayPal account
and you can give us a one-time donation
if you'd like to do that remember our
last movie review check it out if you
haven't already it was the burbs the
1989 jew dante horror comedy and
remember that our regular episodes come
out every tuesday we also have 13
o'clock movie a retrospective that comes
out every friday and 13 o'clock matinee
which is three new movies in the theater
not every Sunday so go check it out if
you haven't already and we will see you
next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]